so for the first time in America's
modern history we have five generations
interacting at work the veterans born
between 1922 and 1943 are known as the
greatest generation the matures the
silence they're known for their
self-sacrifice respect for authority and
work as its own reward
the Boomers came shortly after born
between 1944 and 1960 this is a
generation characterized by hard work in
fact we can fake this generation for the
term workaholic
they appreciate competition they love
effective communication and they're
thinking towards retirement if they
haven't retired already Generation X is
known as the Lost Generation or the
latchkey generation born between 1961
and 1980
the smallest generation sandwiched
between boomers and the big Millennials
they're more parents were divorced in
this generation than any generation
prior they also were the first
generation to tell us about work-life
balance and the first to really ask for
that in the workplace and in Millennials
you know that everybody gets a ribbon
generation born between 1981 and 2000
never knew a time where technology
wasn't present in the home they're
incredibly pragmatic they're hopeful and
they're determined they think they're
gonna change the world in fact I believe
they're gonna do it they might be a
little bit idealistic sometimes but in
just the last several years we've seen
Millennials overtake Generation X to be
the most represented generation in the
workforce in fact more than one in three
people in the United States labor force
is a millennial and soon to join us
there generation Z born since 2000 or
our high school interns are soon to be
high school graduates now if you open
any internet browser look at Amazon
search any of your favorite search
engines you might assume there's a
literal war in the workplace right we
see blog topics like 17 reasons why
Millennials are the worst generation and
why baby boomers have ruined
for everybody are bridging the great
generational divide it's like turning to
this West Side Story like boomers come
in one door Millennials come in another
door the lobby they just fight with each
other all day complaining go home do the
same come back to work right well so
what if I told you these generations may
not exist so I've been spending some
time thinking about this and researching
this and fellow researchers and I aren't
exactly sure that these generations are
real and in fact if we can agree that
these groups even exist we certainly
don't agree who belongs in them and they
span something like 20 years so whatever
point in history a one-year-old and a 20
year old or said to sit share the same
value system to want the same things at
work to have the same stereotypes
working for and against them and in fact
different areas of the world define
these generations differently so we
can't even compare generations across
various areas of the world any
stereotypes about each generation have
in a lot of ways created the
self-fulfilling prophecy that people
begin to act as if they're part of that
generation because we've said out loud
that generation is real I'm not so sure
that it is and in fact this idea of
generations has become deeply embedded
in United States culture when we talk
generations people know exactly what
we're talking about in fact people have
a lot of thoughts and feelings about
each of these generations and I'll tell
you how I know this I did the thing that
every red-blooded American and
pre-tenure academic does and they have a
question
I googled some stuff and this is what I
learned you know so Google is based on
algorithms and they provide you with
commonly searched terms or suggested
hits based on what other people are
searching surrounding the same topic and
it gave me a really good sense of what
people think about each of these
generations take a look
I learned that baby boomers are
conservative but Americans think they're
stupid the worst generation they're
angry apparently they're racist and
they're so important
looking at Generation X I learned
Generation X as a cynical group okay
they're angry they're known as The Lost
Generation we know this okay they're the
smallest generation apparently they're
stupid too
and mostly they're frustrated with baby
boomers part Millennials this is what I
learned about us so we're obsessed with
food
okay we're all so stupid oh okay we're
lazy we're sensitive we're fired
we're all so hated and we think we're
important and perhaps the most
terrifying search result on the internet
generation Z is screwed okay so for five
years I've been talking to leaders and
followers across a wide variety of
organizations and this is what I've come
to realize generations haven't become
part of the conversation generations
have become the conversation at work and
what I've learned is that we're working
another assumption that those Google
results are true and so what I think is
that organizations are now desperate to
figure out how to manage the
multi-generational workplace manage it
right we manage all sorts of things
we're preparing for this wave of
Millennials to come to work so we
prepare for hurricanes right we prepare
to take the MCAT we prepare for natural
disasters why are we preparing for 23
year olds to come to work I've talked to
these organizations and I've heard
amazing things that they're doing to
create a work space for everybody to get
along and to have autonomy and to feel
like they're thriving but I've also
heard some really incredibly harebrained
ideas about how to navigate the
multi-generational workplace are you
ready this is what I saw I visited an
organization and they adopted this idea
that if you can see it you can be it a
really important concept but I think
they blew it they put pictures on the
walls of the ideal multi-generational
workplace because if you can see it you
can be it
or like this one like I don't even want
to work here
I don't where you don't get to wear
color here apparently an HR seriously
has problems with people jumping in
heels I promise you that okay
I talked to an organization who recently
decided against putting a ball pit in
the break room because that's how you
retain Millennials we're 30 not 3 and in
fact I know a young at the time
millennial who was told that if she
wanted people to take her seriously just
because she was a millennial she would
have to do this wear shoulder pads yes
people younger than her and older than
her wouldn't take her seriously unless
she wore shoulder pads straight out of
the 80s can't even buy many more
shoulder pads this young woman had two
graduate degrees this young woman was me
and this is the best we came up with how
to navigate the multi-generational
workplace is shoulder pads so this is
also what I've learned talking
organizations that employ a wide range
of people of various ages we are so much
more similar than we are different and
we're hearing this consistently people
want work that matters they want
flexibility they want support they want
appreciation they want better coffee but
none of these things are tied to a
generation now sure we see small
differences and what people want
we know 20 year olds and 60 year olds go
home and do different things they have
different values at least when it comes
to things happening outside of work but
I think what's happened is that this
focus on generational cohorts these
groups of people has created a space
where we've just forgot that people are
people and don't know who they really
are who we really work with we have to
figure out how to better navigate this
multi-generational workplace than ball
pits call me one of those idealist
Millennials but I think we can get there
and I don't think the idea is too
terribly difficult what if we radically
simply not easily
meet people where they are individualize
our approach I've never met a generation
I've had a lot of conversations with
people who happen to identify with a
specific generational cohort I've met I
know that 80 year olds text message in
23 year olds crochet blankets none of
these things are stereotypical of that
generation right nowa for merchants
she's a thought leader in innovation she
tells us we have to meet people in their
own leanness that is that spot in the
world where only we stand as a function
of our unique history our experiences in
our hopes but this requires flexibility
and curiosity and what happens when we
meet people in their own leanness only
the spot in the world that they stand we
learned that that boomer who's just
acting angry at work all the time is
scared because he's worked every day
since he was 16 years old and in a
Monday sooner than he can imagine he'll
never go to work again he's got plans
it's gonna take like a week and a half
to do all the things on that that
retirement list but then what what I
figure the give a little bit of grace to
the person that might be a little scared
or that generation Xer who has four drop
offs three kids two hands and is just
trying to keep the wheels on the bus
sure maybe she's a little aloof at work
maybe she's a little independent maybe
she's exhausted or that millennial who
asks for a raise after two months
because they're entitled well maybe it's
because that generation has more debt
than any generation before them coming
out of college and they just need the
money to keep going to pay rent and
suddenly when you meet people in their
own leanness that spot in the world only
they stand we're not talking about a
generation anymore
we're talking about Jim or Jen or
Candace and so here's my challenge to us
pick a person just one and explore their
own leanness and then learn and then in
the moments where it's appropriate to
teach and figure out what they bring to
work that no one else can bring to work
because that's what makes work richer
and then do it again and do it again and
then someday we're not working with
generations anymore we're working with
people and so to really understand
beauty of the multi-generational
workplace I think we just have to meet
people where they are and that doesn't
require that we unpack and live there
with them but we might find at least on
occasion it's a beautiful place to visit
and so I think there's just no need to
argue about which generation is the most
angry or the most in title or the most
so obsessed with food we all come to the
classroom to work back to our homes a
little bit tired and a little bit
tattered sometimes maybe let's just our
best to humbly meet people where they
are how they show up that day generation
and all and then those moments where it
can feel a little bit like
intergenerational warfare I think we can
at least all agree that shoulder pads
aren't the solution thank you
[Applause]